teen girls are showing up to the doctor
with ticks experts think anxiety
depression and tick tock could be
playing a role i have motor tick
syndrome something that i've had since
i'm a kid i have tics i have eye tics i
have all kinds of tics um if i don't get
sleep or if i'm eat a lot of sugar and
when have i done that never thank god
i've never done that
but if if if i do these things if i
don't
care for my overall health the ticks
will get worse i do not have the vocal
component of tourette's where i would
yell words that would get me uh kicked
off this
site where you're watching the show i
don't have that
but
people do tourette syndrome is a genetic
nervous system disorder
can cause ticks
repetitive involuntary movements or
sounds it mostly impacts boys and the
tics physically start when a person is
young and then develop over time but
women get them as well and now women's
ticks and you you may know more than me
but i read this article they seem that
they're being exacerbated
by the cut meaning made worse by the
content they're watching on tick-tock
and tick-tock ironically
tick
tock
so these people that have tourette's are
watching people on tik tok and just
stroking out
is that what's going on here yeah it
says doctors noted that what's happening
isn't necessarily true it's not
tourette's but a functional movement
it's a functional movement disorder
because kids want to fit in they want to
fit in
they want a community people all over
the world want a community whether it's
hot people or rich people
or [ __ ] activists
or poets
or [ __ ] some dumb hick they all want
a community and
even
people that any community will do
there the standards for what community
you end up in are not high
people don't care so if you have to
have ticks
as part of
the initiation to get into the community
go hey you tick i tick
we're like this
so
i don't understa so some kids have
pulled out their phones and they show
the doctors uh tick tock and it's full
of these tourette's
cooking and alphabet challenges
now i don't know what those are but i
imagine it's people with tourette's
cooking and just screaming like
different slurs and they're calm and
cooking because it's funny it's funny
when you make an omelette [ __ ] it's
funny
that's funny i'd watch that but i
wouldn't because then maybe i'd tick
more that's the game
and then i can't you know nobody would
believe people don't even believe i do
if i just started saying horrible things
nobody's going to say oh yes tourette no
one would care it's mild tourettes and i
can't get away with anything um like i
have mild homosexuality my homosexuality
is not pronounced but it's it's
effective when it needs to be i i have
sex with men but that doesn't that's not
really what being gay is anymore being
gay is not really having sex with men
it's really dying your hair
it's gone from having sex with men to
dyeing your hair which is much easier to
do having sex with with men
you have to put a a penis in your mouth
like an entire penis or in your butt or
you have to put your penis in someone
else's butt it's a it's a it's an
activity
and dyeing your hair
is is relatively simple you would die in
a purple or a blue or a green and then
not have sex with men women or anyone
but you can be queer
you can be queer and go i'm queer and
you go well what does that mean and they
go
well i don't i reject the gender binary
and i reject
i'm pansexual you go well what does that
mean well i have sex with anyone well
who have you had sex with no not anyone
really
maybe i have to say but usually as i'm
pansexual but i'm not having sex
with a person of the same sex i just
have sex with my boyfriend but i'm a
white woman with blue hair so i'm queer
so it's interesting that i have a very
mild form of homosexuality it has not
progressed into uh dyed hair and the
rejection of the uh actual sex acts
because that's the
that's the heightened form of
homosexuality where you you reject any
and all sexual contact but you replace
it uh with uh fun
uh glitter and hairstyles and things
like that um
some kids have pulled out their phones
they show the doctors hey i'm watching
people with tourette's cook and do
alphabet challenges the jerusalem post
reported that these disorders can be
treated doctors suggest kids take a
social media break
isn't it time to take a break if social
media is giving you tourette syndrome
isn't it time to take a break
if social media
is giving you an involuntary tick
disorder
it might be time
to take a break and i don't know the
like i don't think these kids are
forcing these ticks
this is actually something that is
happening to them right
well you also see communities on tick
tock of people who claim they have like
asperger's or autism right and they love
to uh
what's it called
where they shake i forget what they call
it where they where they do this
together i don't know
overload so it's girls jumping on their
bed doing this because they love to have
autism so it's a lot of like feign they
see that these people are very popular
and a lot of these things are feigned to
be just like interesting you know so i i
think a lot i think a lot of this is
probably fake right i think we've gotten
to a point now where technology i've
made this point at nauseam has flattened
everybody to the point where people
aren't really developing personalities
anymore so the only way to distinguish
themselves is to get a disorder and get
it quick get a disorder and get it quick
anxiety depression tourette's
don't be picky
aspergers anything get on the spectrum
and stay there that seems to be if you
want a social life the best thing you
can do as a child is to develop some
type of disorder on now in the real
world that doesn't work as well but
online people actually gravitate to each
other on the basis of shared horror
shared pain shared problems nobody
online is like i love this and the other
person's like i love that let's together
usually it's like i am suffering i am
also suffering i hate this i also hate
this let's form a bond and all of these
kids their meaningful social
interactions are primarily online so
what they're doing is they're going
online and they're saying who else has a
problem and certain problems look more
fun than others
and i mean and i'm not saying that these
problems aren't real and they don't
exist and that people don't genuinely
have them i'm saying that this word that
nobody likes to use social contagion
everyone hates that because usually when
people talk about it they talk about a
lot of the women that are now
identifying as non-binary
and they're saying you know there are
people that say how many people are
non-binary and the entire class at
oberlin college raises their hand and
you go statistically it's impossible
i come from a time where being a [ __ ]
was special
now not so much now
part of
this social contagion word that people
don't like is because it was used
against gay people and against all you
know we're saying this isn't really who
you are you're just doing this to piss
off tip or gore or something i don't
know remember al gore's fat wife who
didn't like marilyn manson i don't know
if she had a problem with gays but
whatever she didn't like marilyn manson
and i thought he was cool back then not
so much now it's gone in a weird
direction i can't fully support but
antichrist superstar was a good album if
you were a seventh grade goth closeted
gay uh guy who was just starting to
discover uh that you could crush up
pills and put them up your nose
now
people hate that word social contagion
but we're social animals
we exist in a social space and all of
the things we do
primarily are to make ourselves
uh achieve a level of comfort
and then there are people out there that
don't want that level of comfort and
push through it and those are the people
genuinely not always but generally can
accomplish things because to accomplish
things you have to push yourself out of
a comfort zone